allerdings wieder einmal waren und heute
testen wir in ahmsen surprise
adventskalender und den kann man sogar
auf stellen für dumm angemacht ja ich
weiß es ist oktober und es war noch
nicht mal halloween aber ich habe
letztes jahr so gerne dieser
adventskalender auspackt videos geschaut
dass ich mir geschworen habe dieses jahr
auch eins zu machen und man muss auf
youtube schnell sein weil die ganzen
bedeuten diese politikerin die schon
alle ausgepackt den habe ich allerdings
noch nicht gesehen und wenn ihr vorhabt
euch diesen adventskalender zu holen
dann solltet ihr jetzt auf jeden fall
weg scheint und für alle anderen genauso
viel spaß bei den videos haben will come
to the journey through the advent kann
denn jeder der mich kennt weiß dass ich
ein absoluter weihnachts fanatiker bin
deswegen bin ich gerade wirklich
glücklich und aufgeregt türchen nummer
muss sagen dass der vom optischen schon
richtig schön ist und ich absolut keine
ahnung was in diesem päckchen drin sein
kann also lasst uns dass er aus finden
apfel punsch ist das gewürzmischung für
ein heißgetränk aus apfelsaft eine
herrlich aromatisch alternative zu
lieber in rom und unheil mischung für
muffins dass es ein gewürz für fleisch
in so und das ist gemüsebrühe ist auf
jeden fall nummer zwei tornados von
funny-frisch für alle blue chips die
kenne ich aber sonst von der anderen
marke nummer drei also ich habe wirklich
nicht mit so großen sachen gerechnet
spies black tea & breakfast ihm das
reicht locker für so ein zwei tassen pro
tüte
das ist auf jeden fall cool mafia
was ist das getrocknete physalis ein
schokoriegel ohne zucker 1 glutenfreier
was passt das müssen wir auf jeden fall
probieren das glutenfreie melone zucker
okay wenn ihr den intoleranz habt und
kein zucker mögt wodurch diesen
schokoriegel der ist super lecker und
wir müssen auf jeden fall getrocknete
füße alles ausprobieren
ok wo mag es wenn man es mal so cocktail
drauf hat und eine davon ist aber so
getrocknet die zu essen
der schokoriegel hat mich auf jeden fall
überzeugt dass man sich sparen
okay noch finden bis weihnachten bis
weihnachten ist es nicht mehr weit
fliegen ohne witz ich finde das wirklich
cool das sind tolle idee jetzt wenn man
mal so ein adventskalender auspackt
haben also jeden tag im kleinen snack
jetzt kommt nikolaus was ist an nikolaus
transport kartoffeln und tomaten
schmecken
aber ganz ehrlich an nikolaus ist noch
immer das beste drin nummer 7 mio
kokosnuss melodien frei ballaststoff
quelle proteinquelle und einen
organischen kokos plätzchen rezept das
ist cool wenn das jemand schenkt damit
sowas noch nicht gekocht hat der kann
das dann halt auch gleich ausprobieren
und erweitert sein horizont sehr gut
trauma 8 die buße von einer die euch
nochmal sich die body board bogen
gegessen habe die winde hundefutter ok
hundefutter oder schokoladenpudding
eindeutig hindukusch oder schmeckt
genauso wie hundefutter riecht überhaupt
was zum nachspülen immer neu die ist
schwer ein gut für veganer das jetzt
nicht so eine französische spezialität
brathähnchen lecker
ich hab ich doch gerade gesagt der
kalender ist nicht zum vegetarier
cherokee ami ein bisschen fleisch für
morgen ist es richtig gut wir hatten das
angefangen tms lied ein schokoriegel und
jetzt kommt's brathähnchen und biggi
sind aber schon ganz witzig ausland
sieht aus wie baumrinde elf noch ein
energydrink gut vegan kabinen frei mit
stevia oh das ist so eine art energy
drink das mixen mit wasser nummer 12 afl
banane kirche schwarzer reis schwarze
reis wo gibt's denn so was wundert sich
käthe kirchen bei den brechen freunden
natürlich
preisbock banane ja sonst musik ab 1
jahr kannst du dem kind schwarzen heißt
13 13 ist eine große box
okay das ist cool dass bei capri sonne
ich muss mir diese kalender eggert
inspiration nehmen wenn ich jemand
anderem adventskalender basteln möchte
geht halt sehr speck für alle die bis
hier dran geblieben sind cool dass ihr
da seid nummer 14
fleur de sel warm up soll salz aus
indien das ist schon wieder cool für
leute die kochende das mache ich mir
doch gleich auf mein brot keine ahnung
wo man sein boot zeiten sollte 15 noch
mal lese dann machst du hast warst mein
glas und dann tut es einfach nur das
rein und kannst damit berühren weil hier
so löcher drin sind wow das muss jetzt
ausblick wurde recht gut
tsx konntet ihr das schon ich noch nicht
und die 16
was ist das naschkatze müsliriegel mit
zarten flocken und schoko leckereien
wissen alle wie news jährige schmeckt er
muss jetzt probieren 17
egal ob es ist ein 18 bis weihnachten
ist es nicht mehr wahr
das ist das super fit mix aus allen
seiten kernen bären was macht man dann
erst ist so topping für dein hipster
abschiebung mit dieses stück mauer bären
goldkurse sammlung gern langsam
buchweizen cranberries es ist grün frei
irgendwann möglich vergessen scheint
frechen soja und blut
diese bösen blut 18 wird ich dachte es
werden kürzer 18
das probieren wir mal war oder schmeckt
die richtig geschmeckt für sich nicht so
gut
koukou und gehen das schafft graffiti
aus kontrolliertem biologischem aus und
wirklich schätzt das wird auch immer
schärfer
29 10
das ist so schade mit special topic
drauf ja und 1 5 euro gutschein für
deine bestellung genutzt meint chocri
vor xms und dann könnt ihr 5 euro
gutschein bekommen dieses öl du machst
20 bis weihnachten bis weihnachten gibt
noch falsche ruggell marrakesch nummer
und jenix barbecue beendet ein scharfes
riegel und ein leicht scharfen muslime
probieren den 50 prozent schaffen war -
regeln
sieht schön aus nachdem chili öl kann
mich nicht mehr genau
der schmeckt aber bitte lieber
weihnachtsmann lass es nichts paket
richtig lecker sein 21 ein riesenpaket
das kulturcafé um in katyn kost mit
kokosnuss wasser kultur café mit
kokosnuss was er da bin ich richtig
gespannt dem problem ich gleich sofort
nochmal getrocknete muss kern mischung
shaq attack jack driscoll picture liegt
vielleicht am ziel dass mir das gerade
absolut nicht schmeckt ich lasse ihn
manche noch stehen es könnte sein dass
wegen dem chili öl dass mir das noch
nicht so ganz schmeckt probiert zum
schluss noch mal ein so 22 muss wieder
was schwerer weil da chicken wings
bremsen weil das wollte ich mir nämlich
immer kaufen das blockhaus pfeffer aber
ich fand das mal so ein bisschen teuer
und dann dachte ich immer so nötig die
bis fünf euro fünf helfer aus aber das
ist so eine kleine packung das ist cool
ich meine kann man sich dort vielleicht
auch etwas anderes drauf machen oder
mir fällt nämlich gerade eigentlich
wollte das immer kaufen hatte ich noch
fleisch gegessen hat jetzt 20 jahren
nicht mehr mache sich damit anfangen
soll auch irgendwem geschenk ich das
schon
oder ich versuche es mal auch ein
vegetarisches netzes ja vielleicht merkt
dass dann und irgendwie nach bleiweiß
also ich mach das mal früher sehr gerne
einen tag vor weihnachten der 23 viele
kleine inseln autos wieder so knusprige
frage mich ob alle adventskalender
gleich gefüllt sind und ob sie so ein
bisschen variieren aber ich denke mal
alles ist gleich oder in jedem dezember
auch machen vergib mir sagen zum
gleichen sachen hat und da kommen wir
probieren das schmeckt ein bisschen so
wie diese halloren schmeckt wie diese
frucht stäbchen und man den saft immer
so ausdrücken können könnte ich
weihnachten das fest der liebe das fest
der coolen geschenke wenn hier nichts
gutes drin ist dann weine ich es ist
sehr leicht und das macht mich schon
traurig und vierundzwanzigster paket ist
drin ein fein oblaten lebkuchen und noch
ein fein oblaten lebkuchen wow 2d
möglich lebkuchen also da waren in
anderen für und viel bessere sachen
wenn ich jetzt sehr schade probiert noch
mal den kaffee vielleicht spielt jetzt
besser jahre chili geschmack ist
ausnahme und rausgekommen jetzt kann ich
das endlich genießen was war meine
lieblings tür auf jeden fall das
französische brathähnchen das hat mich
komplett überzeugt ich finde das toll
das machen am besten fand ich absolut
diesen scheiß hugo gelingt bin ich
richtig lecker des kokons mir finde ich
auch richtig gut weil ich damit noch nie
gekocht habe das sind so meine zeit
favorite und der tee ich glaube der ist
auch schon gab dazu perfekt jetzt
schenke ich denn irgendwie ich hoffe
natürlich hat das video gefallen wenn ja
dann meinen daumen nach oben und
schaltet auch beim nächsten mal wieder
ein wenn ich irgendwas testet
[Applaus]